I'm with Felix Cohen, who runs the Manhattans Project.
Hi there!
Tell them something they don't know!
So we're going to look at how to do flames out of citrus peels today.
First of all, I'm going to get a drink that we can actually flame,
and make it worthwhile.
So we're going to make a Mandarin Sour with Mandarin Napoleon
We're going to get a double shot of that, the juice of half a lemon
a little bit of sugar syrup going in there. And then also the white of an egg.
And we're going to take an orange. You want to get a nice firm peel on the orange
So this is not a particularly big one but it's got a good feel to it.
And you're going to want to cut a piece roughly the size of a £2 coin.
Try not to bend it at any point. You'll want to keep it as flat as possible.
We've got just a little bit of pith on the back of that.
And then grab a lighter. I like to use a Zippo for this, 'cos you get a better flame out of it
but matches are also good or even just a petrol lighter.
You're going to hold the flame between the orange peel and the glass
and you're going to have the orange peel between first fingers and your thumb. Making sure not to bend it.
And you just want to warm it up gently here.
and that is just breaking open a whole bunch of vessels in the skin of the orange that hold the orange oil
which is what we're going to set on fire.
So once you've warmed it, just hold the flame between it and gently pinch
and you'll get a nice flame out of the orange which is burning the oils and gives the drink a really delicious smell.
-- Thank you very much, Felix!
-- Thank you. Cheers!
-- That is something you might not have known.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]